the california exodus continues it's no
secret residents of the golden state
are relocating here to nevada in big
numbers yeah and in some cases they're
keeping
their jobs in california the i-team's
vanessa murphy continues eight news
now's real estate week
with a look at a long commute
bob martin's commute to work crosses
state lines
it's not too bad i just take long
weekends in in nevada
i am getting tired to drive his job is
in southern california while his
home is in las vegas the drive without
traffic is about four
hours which martin has been doing for
more than a year
he says he was a lifelong california
resident but he and his wife decided it
was time to leave the golden state
he wasn't ready to leave his job though
it's just refreshing to get into nevada
get into las vegas
and leave california on my commute his
home in san bernardino county sold for
more than 600 thousand dollars last year
he and his wife paid less for their
larger summerlin home
we were planning to downgrade in
retirement but we ended up upgrading
to help get an idea of just how many
californians have relocated to nevada
we reached out to the nevada department
of motor vehicles
according to a spokesman in the first
six months of 2021
more than 22 000 californians turned in
their licenses and ids in nevada
especially since covid we've seen a big
influx of people
coming in from california realtor linda
stewart points to the cost of living in
nevada
getting more for your buck in home
values compared to california and
keeping more of your paycheck
california's state income tax tops off
at more than
13 percent while nevadans generally earn
less
the state has no income tax i believe
that there are a lot of people who are
just wanting to get out of there
because they don't agree with how things
are being run martin says he's getting
ready to retire
he won't be making that long commute
anymore and
he may have some new neighbors everybody
i mentioned that i believe
say i want to do the same thing i'm
tired of the state vanessa murphy
8 news now by the way we found a website
called
exitcalifornia.org californians can
research moves to other states and find
services in order to
relocate